we are very quickly seeing a sort of
fork in the republican party
where some republicans are doubling down
on trump people like lindsey graham
who says he's headed down to play golf
with trump in the next week
kevin mccarthy who we just spoke about
who despite a
angry phone confrontation with trump on
january 6th
flew down to florida to recruit trump's
help in winning the house back in 2022
you've got those
people but then you have other
republicans
who are sometimes overtly sometimes a
little more
covertly distancing from donald trump
mitch mcconnell was an incredible
example of this
in his speech moments after the
acquittal of donald trump
in his second impeachment trial this
weekend which we already discussed
another interesting one is republican
nikki haley
haley was the governor of south carolina
she later was donald trump's ambassador
to the united nations
she's completely abandoning donald trump
now and
she says trump quote let us down and
that
we quote shouldn't have followed him
this is arguably the most direct and
forceful rebuke of trump
from strictly political figures that
worked for trump we've seen lots of
rebukes
from secretaries and folks who had more
concrete roles trump's former secretary
of state
trump's former secretary of defense
trump's former
national security adviser john bolton
but
this is different when it's nikki haley
nikki haley's interview with politico
was published going into this weekend
and it's quite stunning she pulls no
punches
let's look at some quotes some of these
are from different parts of the
interview
she says quote he's not going to run for
federal office again
i don't think he's going to be in the
picture i don't think he can
he's fallen so far she says we need to
acknowledge he let us down
he went down a path he shouldn't have
and we shouldn't have followed him and
we shouldn't have listened to him
and we can't let that ever happen again
when i tell you i'm angry it's an
understatement mike
pence has been nothing but loyal to that
man
he's been nothing but a good friend of
that man i am so disappointed in the
fact
that despite the loyalty and friendship
he had with mike pence
that he would do that to him like i'm
disgusted by it
and lastly nikki haley saying i think
he's going to find himself further and
further
isolated i think his business is
suffering at this point
i think he's lost any sort of political
viability he was going to have
i think he's lost his social media which
meant the world to him i mean
i think he's lost the things that really
could
have kept him moving now i want to
repeat once again
this is really important about our
analysis
of what nikki haley and others have been
saying these quotes aren't about
realizing
nikki haley she gets it now she gets she
really gets it
not at all these people are responsible
for trump
in various ways first of all in general
republicans for decades radicalized the
party more and more
so that trump was then able to run and
win in 2016 never would have been able
to win a democratic primary
but they also worked for him despite
knowing this
and this has always been trump nikki
went
and was ambassador to the united nations
for trump despite all the things we knew
about trump
so this is not an analysis of people
having an awakening and all of that
stuff
and these are good republicans this is a
story about
a republican party that is currently
pulling itself apart
or maybe is going to pull itself apart
some newcomers are riding the trump
wave marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
madison cawthorne and others
some long-timers are just sticking with
trump like
lindsey graham some long-timers
seem to be distancing from trump like
mitch mcconnell and others
and then you've got people that were
never really with trump
mitt romney okay yeah he thought maybe
he could be trump's secretary of state
he went and had
turtle soup and frog's legs with trump
early on
but has basically a distance from trump
uh
years and years ago nikki haley wants a
continued political career
she's young she's only 49 compared to
some of these guys in their 70s and 80s
she wants to wash herself of the stink
of trump so now she's going through this
process
and what we're learning here is quite
simply
they knew all along what trump was they
merely
pretended not to know when trump was
their ride
to notoriety or a position of power
or a position of prestige they are even
more immoral than we thought because
they weren't even tricked by trump
if they were really tricked we could say
they're dumb
but they're less immoral they weren't
tricked
they looked away deliberately they knew
all along what it was and they want i
mean look at chris christie
remember chris christie denouncing trump
endlessly during the primary in which he
ran
and lindsey graham too by the way uh
then
standing behind trump figuratively and
literally remember the video of chris
christie standing behind trump
looking like he ate a bad oyster um and
saying yeah
trump trump i'm with trump and then
eventually
chris christie starting to make a little
more sense on trump over the last six
months or so
he knew all along it was just a
calculation how much power can i grab
by attaching myself uh to what was then
the rising star of trump they all knew
all along and none of them deserved to
be forgiven
but from a practical perspective it does
raise questions about the future of the
republican party which we will continue
to talk about